I also know that you get asked about a
sister sister event on probably a daily
yeah
meant like hourly base I would say that
should we just throw it up a window do
we just say no it's not gonna happen you
know it's hard for me to say Never Say
Never
okay because I feel like I'm putting
that into the universe I'm a huge
believer in what you say is what you get
oh so I'm saying never say never because
of that reason but as it stands for
right now there's nothing to report but
there could be conversations happening
there's no conversation there is nothing
to report unfortunate okay but like I
say I don't who knows who knows I mean
look what happened with will grace and
people I think just love the nostalgia
yeah yeah and I think people love you
and your sister together and even Tosh
you know we do to get you guys to work
together again in a different capacity
oh my gosh well I was just saying
earlier maybe do a Christmas movie
together
could you imagine all of us doing a
Christmas movie together the last time
we did a movie together was in 2000
oh gosh maybe nine so it's been 10 years
oh yeah it's been a while maybe even
longer than that maybe we did a movie
called seventeen again and it was all
three of us I think it's been more than
ten years yeah but for all of us to do a
movie together it would be so epic and a
Christmas do you guys talk about this
though the three of you at least well I
will say this Tamara and I we've always
talked about it okay we're always like
what is that next thing yeah you know a
lot of pressure I imagine to it is
because it's about finding the right
thing and then also finding something
that's fitting our schedules you know as
she's on the reel and that's a very
intense schedule it really is an intense
job hearing so much of herself you are
you are and then my brother on the other
hand you know he's older and he's like
oh
you know hang out with my sisters Tia
Mowry spilling on her famous family to
et and hopefully they'll share the
screen together again you talk a little
bit about your sister being on the wheel
would you ever join permanently a show
like that you've been on there a few
times yeah that's a good question you
know I really think that I don't know I
don't know like you said being a host on
a talk show it's hard yep
you know it's very very hard you have to
be extremely vulnerable and I'm gonna be
honest with you sometimes you don't have
a choice oh when you're not like I can
choose on what I want to share right
when you're on a panel with so many
different women and if they're sharing
things okay how do you feel like you
have to oh and if you don't then it's
like you stand out you know what I mean
so I'm not speaking for my sister I'm
sure that's what she does but I do see
what she does on a daily basis and I
don't know if I could I don't know if I
could I'm not sure you know what I mean
but I don't know but Never Say Never
that's the key that's the key phrase
here Never Say Never
the mom of two is also getting candid
about her kiddos you welcomed your
daughter a little over a year by decree
adjusting to being a big brother you
know I'm very real inauthentic when it
comes to this question at first it was
hard because he was the king of the
house for eight years and then here
comes this beautiful princess yeah but I
felt so terrible because I didn't know I
was doing it and my son was like mommy
you give um Cairo more kisses than me
did that break your horse
yeah and that I literally had to
readjust and be like okay Tia you have
to be careful about what you were doing
in front of him so to answer your
question he has fully adjusted he is
it's been 17 months if not by now
something would be wrong he's the best
big brother in the world and I think
what's really helped is just being
mindful of what I'm saying in front of
him in doing and try to keep it equal
and then also explaining to him she
needs more attention because she can't
do the things that you can do and then
also incorporating him in the routine so
he'll help me with throwing away the
diaper if it's you know the pooping one
he's like no help me get the bottles and
watching her and doing all that he is
amazing does the family feel complete
now you have a boy and a girl you know
it's so weird because at first I thought
that but then I'm like I know this is
weird you guys but when I look at our
old Christmas photo that we you know -
every year with a family I'm like it
looks like there needs to be another one
there
it's weird but I'm up and down with
wanting another child yeah I don't know
if I feel complete yet but I am happy
I'm happy with you know where everything
is right now and yeah so I I can't
complain let's just say that yeah you
did say earlier you are a very authentic
person and I think that's what people
love about you you look at your
Instagram you're sharing all sorts of
things and I think you're inspiring
people and inspiring conversations
that's what motivates me to do what I do
is it do you read the comments of it
because I do I do and that's what drives
me and I will say the first time I ever
became vulnerable was when I shared my
story with endometriosis and I was very
scared to do that was scared because we
being I'm being real we live in a
society that celebrates perfection
not just we're not really open to
embracing our flaws right if you see a
wrinkle you want to face tune it if you
whatever we live in that we live in that
world and you know I was afraid of
showing and expressing my glitch my flaw
but bins not a flaw by the law thank you
but what really made me change my mind
was my story was too wonderful and it's
all about seeing food as medicine and
how changing my diet really helped my
existing condition and I said I can't
keep that call to myself I want to
inspire I want to share with other women
hope and that's why I did it so I became
inspired by myself and so that's where I
am now that's what I am motivated by and
even with the Christmas movie that I did
or the movies in the projects I had just
finished having my daughter I still had
my deli and again we live in a society
that celebrates perfection you see a lot
of people going snapping back you know
which is funny it's not easy but some
women
that's not how their body works and I
wanted them to see that yes I did a
movie and I didn't wait until I lost
twenty thirty pounds this is me this is
who I am I love Who I am and I'm not
gonna say no because I'm afraid of
rejection I'm not gonna say no because
I'm afraid of someone saying nasty
things no I said I'm gonna do it because
I want women to see and be inspired that
just because you have a baby and just
because you don't look perfect it
doesn't mean that you can't walk outside
and continue to do what you love to do
you know having children wasn't always
easy for me and to be able to I think
children are miracles and be able to
just have this beautiful I call my
princess RORO cuz we made his cairo so
we go princess
robo princess ro e she just lights up my
day and I'm not taking away from my son
but the reason is because I'm women and
I know that she wound up growing up to
be a woman and it's just everything that
I do is so purposeful you know what I
mean with her and what I'm teaching her
and I tell her how beautiful she is
every day and some people may think that
that's superficial you know you're so
cool you're so beautiful but I call her
beautiful every day because I want her
to know that she is you know next for
the 41 year old a new lifetime holiday
movie premiering November 27 I'm a
sucker for Christmas but one thing
that's really special about this movie
is there's this mystery so there's
Christmas in the background but in the
forefront there's this mystery and I
play Dodie bright who loves all things
vintage and she's obsessed with these
vintage pieces because she she's
obsessed with the story that comes along
with it she wants to know who what where
when why you know she wants to know the
story I didn't like that in real life by
the way I'm I'm I'm not like that with
material things but I'm like that in
real life with people you're like well
person can from let me look at their
Instagram yet I am a psych major so I
you know when Deborah dying University
and I graduated with a psych degree and
I'm so obsessed with why people behave
the way they behave like what's their
story when I apply that to this to this
character but I think that's just what's
so amazing about a very vintage
Christmas is there's this search that
she goes on after finding this
mysterious box of all of these artifacts
and she wants to find out who these you
know
or what these pieces belong to or who
these pieces belong to and what are
these pieces that's what I meant and
it's just it's it's funny it's it's a
nice ride I think yeah
[Music]